as demand for individual mobility Rises
so does consumption of Natural Resources
white fossil fuels but supplies of oil
and gas are finite and they pollute the
environment there is no shortage of
ideas for eco-friendly ancients but it
doesn't look like the car industry has a
plan for radically reducing co2
emissions any time soon
audi is intensifying its focus on
developing plug-in hybrid powertrains
that combine conventional combustion
engines and electric motors Siegfried
fint leader of Audis electric motor
Research Unit says there will be a
combination of power trains conventional
engines will endure for years or decades
for some models but electric motors will
become mainstream to Audi is actively
advancing e-mobility recently the
automaker introduced a second plug-in
hybrid model to join the a3 e-tron the
q7 short chance like inner city driving
can be done using only electric power
but on longer journeys of over 50
kilometers the regular combustion engine
has to kick in Audi's a7h stron Quattro
does away with the combustion engine
altogether and is powered by fuel cells
the drive system uses a chemical
reaction to turn hydrogen into water and
electricity this in turn powers the a7's
electric motor if and when the a7h stir
on we'll go into mass production is
unclear howdy says there are still too
few hydrogen fuel stations to make the
fuel cell vehicle a mainstream success
let's do a bunch of Vince says that fuel
cells are strategically promising that's
because they build on conventional
electricity powered cars with batteries
and electric powertrains Audi's each one
quattro concept car is the manufacturers
first attempt at designing an
all-electric vehicle the volume
production model is expected to be
launched in 2018 it has a 95 kilowatt
hour battery pack enough for a range of
over 500 kilometers combined output will
be at least 300 20 kilowatts studied in
licensing phone in distance toilet
sponsors kavi the battery capacity is
crucial for the cars range audi sees
potential for improvements here are you
taking a lithium-ion batteries are still
in their infancy in the near future
development chief line HUD hoffman
expects that energy density will
increase while prices will drop a little
deposit Astana struck in the hole again
these new technological frontiers also
allow for new developments in the cars
design vallinam it'll interior designer
Maximilian fish hopper says that they
can break apart the center console to
create space since the entire powertrain
and transmission are gone and gradually
this should be reflected in the design
all of the displays feature Oh LED
technology meaning that the wafer thin
screens can be cut to any size or shape
that fought the advantage according to
the designer is that they can give our
architecture the desired shape and make
the O LED elements and the display to
match that gives his team lots of
creative freedom and makes for
progressive design kolkata vistas on
over 50 pop-out cameras replace the
outside mirrors which saves on weight
on the hood and at the rear
electronically controlled aerodynamic
elements regulate the airflow as
necessary zigfried pin says the
optimized exterior is seventy to
seventy-five percent finished so you can
expect to see this figure and these
design characteristics when the car goes
into series production all electric cars
are the future but at present
electricity is still largely generated
in power plants whether it's produced by
burning coal or gas or through nuclear
technology all of these means of
generating electricity are harmful to
the environment the key to creating
truly eco-friendly electric cars is to
harness more energy from renewable
sources such as wind water and the Sun
because electricity is also needed to
produce the hydrogen for fuel cell
vehicles there's still a long road ahead
before cars can truly be considered
emissions-free